cher monsieur premier ministre maudit
cher monsieur le secrétaire
jean ping président ses présidents
ramaphosa monsieur le président maurice
hoarau tout d'abord je voudrais me
joindre à tous les collègues qui se sont
exprimés et remercier monsieur premier
ce maudit et tous nos amis indiens
pour le travail actif qui l'ont mené
et l'inde en tant que président du brics
jusqu'à l'année prochaine a fait un
grand travaux malgré la pandémie
coronavirus
le gouvernement indien a fait tout ce
qui était possible pour que le
partenariat stratégique entre les pays
du bric se développe de façon cohérente
donc l'autorité de notre union comme ça
est exprimé par les collègues ne fait
que se renforcer et son rôle dans les
affaires étrangères s'impose aussi
et c'est le fait que en quinze ans de
travail nous avons réussi à mettre en
place un mode de coopération sur
l'ensemble des problèmes qui sont à
l'ordre du jour le partenariat
stratégique correspond à une demande
dans la mesure où notre monde et
particulièrement troublé aujourd'hui il
ya eu la pandémie comme ça a été dit à
l'instant
et c'est une menace qui s'est manifestée
sur tous les aspects de notre vie sur la
vie économique internationale sur les
problèmes sociaux et donc la situation
dans le monde reste tendue la
sécurité mondiale est toujours menacée
et il faut travailler pour la stabilité
stratégique et donc on voit aujourd'hui
les conflits régionaux se
connaître un regain et le retrait des
troupes américaines et de l'otan de
l'afghanistan a su susciter beaucoup de
nouveaux problèmes et on ne sait pas
encore toujours quelles seront les
conséquences pour la stabilité régionale
et la sécurité
donc il est tout à fait juste de dire
que nos pays sont particulièrement
sensibles à cette question bien
évidemment la russie comme partenaires
des brics se prononce pour
l'établissement d'une
dune sécurité d'une stabilité
ça fait des dizaines d'années que
les peuples demandent de pouvoir se
prononcer sur leur sort et nous sommes
intéressés pour que l'afghanistan
plus être un gage de sécurité n'ont pas
une menace pour la région
il ya des menaces de terrorisme et de
trafic de drogue
et nous sommes pour limiter les flux de
migration et que les afghans puissent
vivre en paix sur leur terre natale
je l' ai souvent dit que la crise
d'aujourd'hui en afghanistan est une
conséquence directe de la volonté
d'imposer un mode
politiques et sociales sur d'autres pays
et ce sont ces mots de décès structures
démocratiques qui sont imposés sans
prise en compte des réalités culturelles
historiques et des traditions tout
simplement dans lesquelles vivent les
autres pays tout cela
ne fait que l'aggraver
las la sécurité l'instabilité et
provoqué le chaos a pressé les
expériences j'espère que les pays
feront
attention à l'évolution à donner donc
c'est un défi pour toute la communauté
internationale et
nous nous prononçons pour un
développement des relations
dans le cadre d'un dialogue entre toutes
les forces politiques pour dans le
respect mutuel des intérêts politiques
et économiques des prix tout en
respectant les règles du droit
international qui sont fixés dans la
charte de l'onu sans ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures il est important
aussi de soutenir au niveau mondial des
relations constructives respectueuses
renforcer le système multipolaire
et en travaillant avec des centres
différents
des centres de force économiques et
politiques et justement se sentent
correspondent aux activités des brics
dont on continue on travaille avec nos
partenaires et c'est un travail qui
semaine toute l'année
et c'est sur la part de cet héritage de
consolidation et de travail de
coopération que nous pouvons travailler
pour l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
le groupe des cinq pays duris joue un
rôle majeur
j'espère que notre travail d'aujourd'hui
sera détaillé concret et encore une fois
je tiens à souligner que la russie est
prête à coopérer avec tous les pays des
brics sur toutes les orientations je
vous remercie